sometimes actors should just leave their
clothes on nude scenes in cinema range
from exciting to downright awful and
we've compiled the worst of the worst
apologies to Hal Berry and Howard the
Duck because these revealing moments
seriously dragged their movies down
nobody ever expected the Harald and
Kumar movies to be highbrow Cinema but
it's safe to say that some fans hope
that 2008's Harald and Kumar escaped
from Guantanamo Bay would offer some
amusing social commentary with a title
as lengthy and descriptive as that how
could the movie not Lampoon America's
post 911 policy unfortunately calpan and
John Cho spent barely 10 minutes inside
the infamous prison for terrorists
before escaping and reverting back to
the world of Meandering Stoner comedy no
one has anything smart or even
interesting to say about race or
politics not even a fake George W bush
has much to say other than smoking pot
is fun dude this is
weed that's Alabama Coos that's saw the
finest the film hits Rock Bottom during
the scene in which Hal and Kumar attend
a bottomless party tired of the topless
party Trend their friend razza decides
to host a rave that he is convinced is
the most Innovative idea since jello
shots his dresser code requires that
everyone in attendance must wear nothing
from the waist down plenty of gratuitous
nudity ensues we could possibly forgive
this one if the scene was gender
balanced but the male gaze is very
strong with this one despite showing
dozens of bottomless women there's only
one man who actually gets exposed from
the front and it's played for Laughs of
course if it wasn't for one particular
scene swordfish would have been
remembered as just another cyber crime
Thriller from the early 2000s instead
swordfish is remembered as that one
weirdly sexual cyber crime Thriller from
the early 2000s if Hugh Jackman being
pleasured while hacking into the
Department of Defense isn't weird enough
for you the movie also features a
completely Superfluous scene of hi
Barry's sunbathing topless director
Dominic Senna allegedly put a little
extra cash in Barry's paycheck in
exchange for flashing her breasts Senna
claimed that Barry was reluctant at
first to go nude until he offered her a
$500,000 bonus for it of course Barry
insisted in a later interview that Senna
was just being flippant when he said
that instead she claimed that she agreed
to strip down for the role not because
of money but because she finally felt
confident enough to film a nudes scene
for the first time in her career she
told Entertainment Weekly with the
success of my Dorothy d project and the
critical Acclaim that brought me I
finally felt that I didn't have to prove
myself anymore regardless of how much
Barry was paid to show off her nudity
doesn't serve much of a purpose other
than getting teenage boys excited
huh this looks friendly as far as spring
break movies are concerned the only
thing you're more likely to see than a
man chugging beer is a woman with her
top off Piranha 3D is no exception but
it takes things a step further by having
those topless women get mauled to death
by a school of carnivorous fish piranha
3D is a 2010 remake of the original
piranha from 1978 which itself is a
bovie ripoff of Jaws a piranha remake
with a much bigger budget was a
reasonable idea at first but the
inclusion of countless three-dimensional
breasts pretty much ensured that it
would never be much more than a
cinematic novelty some of the sequences
in Piranha 3D come across a straight up
pornographic which makes sense
considering that several of the main
characters are hard at work making an
adult film of their own some of the most
gratuitous moments in the movie involve
these characters like the overly long
scene in which two models wearing
nothing but flippers swim around to
classical music leaning into the sexy
angle seemed to work financially for
Piranha 3D as it earned $83 million on a
$24 million budget and got a sequel
called piranha 3 DD still it's
definitely a movie that would have been
better if it was focused Less on human
skin and more on the blood and guts
under it Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah is a
beautifully heartbreaking piece of music
it's been used to great effect in movies
of all genres from dark dramas like Lord
of War to family films like Shrek Zack
Snider understood this when he decided
to put the song in his 2009 adaptation
of Watchmen but he didn't seem to
realize that the song isn't exactly sexy
as far as sex scenes go the one in
Watchman isn't terrible if you hit the
mute button night owl and Silk Spectre
rescue some people from a burning
building and they're so intoxicated by
the thrill of becoming superheroes again
that they hook up right there in the owl
ship World War III could start
tomorrow right it's a moment more or
less lifted from the comics but what the
comics don't have is a soundtrack it's
hard to say what a good song choice
would be for this particular moment but
Hallelujah is definitely not the ideal
pick it's a tortured meditation on the
destructive nature of love not something
that you'd put on a sexy playlist even
if you ignore the bizarre needle drop
there are still a couple issues Patrick
Wilson and malen arriman find themselves
in some pretty Twisted poses inside the
cramped Airship and the conveniently
timed Jed of flame right at the
climactic moment is pretty laughable who
watches the Watchmen we have but this
makes us wish we hadn't plenty of men
say they want a woman who's adventurous
in the bedroom but a lot of them would
get scared if their partner ended up
being kinkier than they are that's what
happens to Vince Von's character and
Wedding Crashers as he ends up in a
compromising position with his
girlfriend Gloria played by IA fiser in
the middle of the night night Jeremy
awakens to a pair of nipples in his face
he discovers that Gloria has tied him to
his bed and then climbed on top of him
because she's afraid that Jeremy will
lose interest in her if she's not more
exciting and adventurous their dialogue
is funny but the nudity is definitely
unnecessary no one feels this more
strongly than Isa Fisher herself who
told the film's producers that it would
be a bad idea to show her character
naked Fisher argued that the moment her
character shows too much skin the
audience will see her as eye candy
instead of comic relief alas fer lost
the battle for the comedic Integrity of
her character and the nude scene made
the final but to compensate for her
sexualization she decided to dial up her
performance to an 11 she told
Entertainment Weekly I thought to combat
the fact that you're going to see her
boobs I have to make her even more
extreme for us to still get a laugh God
don't ever leave me ever good cuz I'd
find
you 16 Candles is one of the most
inappropriate PG movies of all time this
High School Coming of Age story is aimed
at the teenage demographic even though
it contains plenty of sexual content
that would be decidedly R-rated nowadays
while the movie is centered around a
compelling female protagonist there is
at least one scene that very much comes
across as directed by a man John Hughes
specifically in the girls locker room
Samantha Baker admires the body of her
popular classmate Caroline as she
showers clearly feeling like her own
body can never compare this would have
been a decent introspective moment if
the movie didn't linger far too long on
Caroline's bare breasts in fact the
script contains stage directions that
read and this is true closeup the
world's most perfect breasts so much for
character development it's pretty clear
this moment was included to please horny
teenage boys and the movie's themes of
positive body image get lost somewhere
in the steam surely there was another
way to convey that Samantha feels that
she isn't in the same league as Caroline
one that didn't involve the bare breasts
of a Teenage character with a title like
Howard the Duck it seems at first glance
that Willard hk's 1986 film about an
anthropomorphic water foul might be
suitable for kids however parents who
brought their little ones to see it in
theaters found themselves covering their
children's eyes when they saw not one
but two naked ducks in the first few
minutes the opening credits haven't even
finished by the time Howard reclines in
his armchair and opens a copy of play
duck magazine which features a topless
duck modeling some lingerie then once
Howard and his armchair are sucked into
a wormhole he zooms past another duck in
the bathtub with her feathered breasts
clearly visible the camera lingers on
this naked background character even
after Howard is gone throwing a
commercial for jock itch and Howard's
girlfriend telling him about her erotic
dream and the opening sequence is oozing
with sex that's probably not something
they were expecting to see in a George
Lucas produced adaptation of a comic
about a talking duck even though Howard
has made a cameo in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's pretty unlikely that we'll
be seeing any birds with breasts in the
next Avengers
movie the room is a bad movie in fact
you might even consider it the worst
movie Tommy wo's absurd melodrama breaks
every single rule of film making but
there's a reason why midnight showings
of the aul flick still attracts soldout
crowds of enthusiastic spoon throwers
it's bad in an incredibly entertaining
way except for the sex scenes those are
just regular bad in the room main
character Johnny is a good man beloved
by all except his girlfriend Lisa who
decides to break his heart by cheating
on him with his best friend so how does
the movie show how much Johnny cares
about Lisa by subjecting viewers to one
of the most embarrassing sex scenes ever
to make it to the screen the sequence is
indulgently long and shot more like a
softcore porno than an actual piece of
Cinema the sex lasts exactly as long as
the song playing in the background as if
it never occurred to wio to time skip a
bit or cut the song short considering
that wio wrote directed produced and
starred in the room all at once it's
possible that he was just looking for an
excuse to get freaky on camera if that's
really what wiso wanted he's certainly
gotten his wish millions of people
around the world have seen him show off
his bare butt did you lack last night
yes I
did one nude scene from Last hang on
Paris is shocking not because of the
scene itself but because of what
happened during its production in the
notorious moment Marlin brandoo Paul
uses a stick of butter as a lubricant
when he assaults Maria Schneider's Johan
Schneider knew she would be filming a
scene in which her character was being
assaulted but director Bernardo bertuchi
omitted one crucial detail that Marlon
Brando would be smearing butter all over
her body baluchi sprang it on Schneider
because he wanted to use her real
reaction in the final film Schneider
told the Daily Mail they only told me
about it before we had to film the scene
and I was so angry to add insult to
injury baluchi told the guardian that he
felt Schneider was just inexperienced as
he put it she was a 19-year-old who had
never acted before maybe
sometimes in the movie I didn't tell her
what was going on because I knew her
acting would be better after last hango
in Paris Schneider became overwhelmed by
Fame and her career was never the same
the media soon became less concerned
with her acting and more interested in
finding scandals in her personal life if
you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault help is available
visit the rape abuse and incest National
Network website or contact Reign's
National helpl line at 1 1800 656 hope